[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de
pavot balayer une actualité chargée
puisque c'est une semaine décisive pour
la réforme des retraites avec les grands
mouvements de grève qui s'annonce jeudi
est-ce que voilà ce qu'ils vont déborder
dans l'opinion est-ce que l'opinion va
suivre ce mouvement ou pas c'est un des
enjeux de cette semaine on va parler
aussi de l'école avec le retour comme ça
d'un serpent de mer
l'uniforme à l'école soutenu par
Brigitte Macron notamment mais avec une
proposition aussi de loi du
rassemblement national et puis on
parlera aussi dans sondage à mon avis à
s'inquiétant qui montre que les jeunes
sont de moins en moins crois de moins en
moins science et de plus en plus à ce
qu'on appelle les vérités alternatives
et pour parler de tous ces sujets et
d'autres Armel Le Bras Chopard bonjour
vous êtes politologue vous êtes
professeur de vous étiez professeur de
sciences politiques vous êtes l'auteur
grand nombre de livres le dernier
c'était femme et République on en avait
parlé ici qui est paru à la
Documentation française vous avez aussi
obtenu le prix Médicis de l'essai pour
votre récit sur le zoo des philosophes
voilà donc on est ravi de vous
accueillir comme de temps en temps vous
êtes déjà venu expliquer
et fondatrice avec Bruno Jérôme de du
site élections Coop qui regarde le
comportement des Français qui permet au
fond de
prédire un peu les des mieux que les
sondages des résultats des élections
souvent mieux que les sauvages
surtout surtout de façon plus précoce si
précoce Jean-Charles dit bonjour bonjour
à tous éditeur et voilà le dernier roman
c'est vous avez pas oublié vous avez pas
oublié de la porter mais ça serait le
roman
de Jean-Michel Lecoq alors Jean-Michel
le coq c'est un auteur vous suivez son
cinquième hein c'est son 5e livre chez
nous et là c'est original j'imagine que
vous connaissez grand érudit Emile
gaboriot
enfin le créateur le père durant
policier quasiment et du 19e siècle et
cette fois Jean-Michel Lecoq Kiss une
intrigue qui se passe à moitié en ce
moment et à moitié autant des 1000
gaboriaux qui auraient qui a écrit un
livre qui a disparu voilà et donc
le héros de Jean-Michel le coq se
précipite sur les traces des mines
gaboriaux pour essayer de retrouver ce
roman oublié et voilà il y a une double
intrigue c'est un héros récurrent c'est
un commissaire le commissaire payardais
ce qui est amusant
Michel Lecoq s'appelle donc le coq c'est
pas un pseudo et le héros des 1000
gaboriaux s'appelle l'inspecteur Lecoq
donc il a fait 50 livres avec
l'inspecteur de quoi
sinon
bonjour vous êtes avocat au Barreau de
Versailles c'est un secrétaire de la
Conférence du stage absolument et je
vais commencer tout de suite par vous
parce qu'on devait parler la semaine
dernière de l'affaire Houellebecq vous
savez il y avait une menace de plainte
de la Grande Mosquée de Paris qui a
finalement été retiré mais
finalement il y a quand même une plainte
qui est déposée absolument pas triste
finalement alors on avait évoqué le
sujet un petit peu la semaine dernière
concernant la recevabilité d'une plainte
est-ce que pourrait éventuellement
envisager sur le plan du droit à la
grande mosquée de France finalement elle
n'avait pas déposé plainte elle n'avait
pas saisi un quelconque tribunal
correctionnel pour faire valoir ses
droits mais mais l'union de des mosquées
de France à elle décidé de porter
plainte contre Michel Houellebecq
Michel Onfray et la revue frontale
discrimination à la haine et à la
violence contre les musulmans d'accord
voilà donc finalement il y a peut-être
finalement un procès alors si alors ça a
été déposé au tribunal judiciaire de
Nanterre si le tribunal le parquet de
Nanterre estime que l'infraction est
caractérisée ou que éventuellement il
faut juger l'un ou l'autre ou les trois
pour cette infraction là alors il y aura
peut-être un procès oui c'est pas encore
sûr
maintenant c'est dans les mains du
procureur de la République de Nanterre
qui va et infiner décider si il y a
nécessité ou non d'un procès sur cette
infraction et sur ces faits et sur ces
propos ça sera forcément sur les trois
parce que de toute façon vous c'est les
propos qui ont été tenus dans une revue
publiée on ferait et
ne sont que complices et en fait celui
qui qui commet la faute supposée c'est
le directeur publication de la revue ça
c'est clair
si vous par exemple aujourd'hui vous
vous en direct vous dites quelque chose
de d'infammant c'est pour vous si c'est
une émission enregistrée c'est pour
tirer barbelette voilà donc on va dire
que c'est enregistrer comme ça
[Rires]
il n'y aura donc pas de propos infamant
aujourd'hui à part
ici et vous êtes venus en voiture non
de la publicité mais en Normandie c'est
mon chef à Paris
c'est toujours intéressant c'est vrai
que les les
responsabilités des médias dans ce genre
d'affaires parce que il y a de l'essence
je crois qu'il y a pas de pénurie mais
tout le monde a peur qu'il y a une
pénurie tout le monde se précipite dans
les stations services et c'est terrible
quoi c'est contre-productif parce que
finalement on ne fait que qu'avancer que
déplacer le problème alors peut-être que
ça coupe l'air pour sous le pied ou
syndicat n'auront plus grand chose
agiter comme sur fond rouge mais le
problème c'est que on peut pas reprocher
non plus à ceux qui travaillent d'abord
anticipé et de
sur cette annonce ces syndicats sont
très crédibles on sait exactement ce que
ça produit de d'avoir des raffineries
encore que la CGT est assez mesurée sur
le fait de savoir si il faut que
les syndicats qui s'occupent justement
des pétrole face
à une action dans les raffinerie parce
que c'est pas très populaire on va
peut-être t'en parler tout à l'heure
mais effectivement quand même une un peu
particularité grandissante de de des
actions menées principalement par la CGT
qui sont extrêmement français
le sujet de tout à l'heure on va
commencer peut-être par quelque chose
qui est assez intéressant pourquoi ça
revient sur le devant de la scène et ben
c'est le la question du retour de
l'uniforme à l'école
[Musique]
un peu une surprise c'est-à-dire qu'au
moment où le rassemblement national
déposait une proposition de loi ou
défendez une proposition de loi à
l'Assemblée sur le retour de l'uniforme
à l'école dans Le Parisien Brigitte
Macron est première dame donc qui était
interrogé ce disait favorable à ce
retour de l'uniforme c'est un vieux
débat alors le débat est ancien ce qui
est nouveau est complètement surprenant
c'est l'intervention de la femme de
d'Emmanuel Macron ça donne rien à voir
dans le dans le débat actuel qui est
autrement plus large et autrement plus
important et en plus elle n'a absolument
aucun titre à intervenir dans un débat
public que ce soit l'uniforme que ce
soit
l'orthographe l'écriture inclusive la
pédagogie
absolument c'est une citoyenne comme les
autres alors
à la suite de son intervention il y a eu
évidemment des réactions compris un
deuxième article dans Le Parisien et
l'Élysée a répondu ah ben oui mais elle
a pas envie d'être une petite mais on
s'en fiche que et Brigitte Macron est en
vie ou non d'être une petite personne
vous avez pas envie d'être une potisse
moi non plus
nous apporte comment une personne qui
n'a absolument quinté qui n'est pas élu
qui n'est pas nommé
intervient et court-circuite le ministre
de l'éducation nationale
il s'était déjà prononcé en disant non
il y aura pas d'obligation au niveau
national même si tel ou tel
établissement peut dans son règlement
mettre des
uniformes etc c'est c'est absolument
incroyable et c'est un acte qui est
politique alors qu'elle n'a pas
intervenir en politique ces politiques
n'ont pas tellement sur le fond et sur
le sujet
précisément parce qu'elle va à
l'encontre d'un ministre de la
République qui lui a une fonction
officielle et puis deuxièmement parce
que elle intervient sur une proposition
de du rassemblement national qui n'est
quand même pas n'importe quel parti
politique
en même temps on peut dire elle a été
enseignante
peut-être une légitimité personnelle
politique vous avez raison tout à fait
institutionnel vous avez tout à fait
raison peut-être après tout est-ce
qu'elle peut ou pas donner de des avis
de personnels sur un sujet bon alors
nous on va y aller
dans on a le droit à nous d'ailleurs en
tant que citoyenne d'intervenir mais pas
justement elle est pas elle lui
intervient elle ne pourrait intervenir
et avoir une voix et qui soit répercuté
dans les journaux que parce qu'elle est
l'épouse du président
non pas au titre de
toute la journée la parole n'importe
quel abruti dans des micro-trottoirs sur
toutes les chaînes de télévision sont
pas pourquoi Brigitte Macron n'aurait
pas le droit de s'exprimer
d'accordiez du ministre de l'Éducation
enfin lui il est vraiment à géométrie
variable il imprime pas personne ne le
connaît il dit un jour oui un jour non
un jour blanc un jour noir enfin je veux
dire bon je l'ai c'est peut-être bien
comme moi quelqu'un est un avis alors
après on va discuter
pourquoi pas elle reprend la thèse de
Ségolène Royal qui à l'époque qui avait
pas disjoncté et qui était encore
intéressantes et qui effectivement
voulait le retour du
débat il y a deux choses
[Musique]
politiques
il y a pas de statut au fond de la
première dame des pièces jaunes alors il
faut il faut lui dire
que les présidents d'une fondation qui
est une fondation privée alors
évidemment c'est très ambigu parce que
c'est fondation elle est quand même
financée plus ou moins par par l'État
mais elle intervient là il y a rien à
dire c'est ambigu c'est équivoque mais
il y a rien à dire et ça c'est très
excitant toutes les premières dames ont
fait ça oui
là sur le alors
sur le plan institutionnel je crois que
c'est incontestable qui a pas de statut
de la de la première vague donc malgré
le est-ce que cela dit est-ce que parce
qu'il y a pas de statut ça n'interdit
vous vous dites ça ne m'interdit de de
de donner une opinion sur le sur le
champ politique mais totalement
totalement ne doit pas intervenir dans
le champ politique est-ce qu'il y avait
un statut faudrait voir ce qu'il y a
dans ce statut et déjà dans la Charte il
y a des choses où les avec les missions
qui lui incombe et qui sont inscrits
dans cette short qui n'a aucune valeur
juridique c'est déjà très limite sur le
plan politique d'accord moi ça
m'intéresse plus quand même de savoir de
connaître l'avis de Brigitte Macron sur
l'uniforme que la vie de Michel Obama
sur la façon de confectionner les
sandwichs pour son mari dans les
cuisines de la Maison Blanche et
personne ne se fusée de ce livre
ridicule donc
de la première d'amour
d'être rémunéré
d'intervenir et
Hillary Clinton s'était fait remettre à
sa place sur la réforme du système de du
système de santé mais oui mais bon
vous dites que c'est plus intéressant
d'avoir la vie de Brigitte Macron
pourquoi bon parce que vous la trouvez
intéressante moi je la trouve pas
spécialement j'ai aucune passion pour
Brigitte Macron
après c'est une question
de son mari puisqu'elle dit qu'elle
intervient uniquement parce que elle est
d'accord avec son mari était méchante
cela dit elle a bien dit dans le et
c'est dit dans le journal que
elle elle quand elle est d'accord avec
son mari donc quand elle est pas
d'accord elle se tait cela dit c'est pas
la première fois je m'en souviens de de
dernière vidéo par exemple qui
intervenait assez assez régulièrement et
qui mettait parfois en difficulté son
président
elle a été critiquée là-dessus elle
avait pas intervenir mais là aussi cette
astucieux parce qu'à l'intervenait au
nom de sa fondation je ne pense qu'une
nationalité la plus la plus libre la
plus émancipée de toutes les premières
dames effectivement c'est pas le cas
poser de patron de se situe pas dans ce
cas-là il y a eu aussi Cécilia Sarkozy
qui part en Libye à titre alors oui ça
c'était envoyé spécial
aussi est-ce que c'est le plan
institution vous voulez continuer à
aussi le fond du problème celui du celui
du port ou pas du port
vous avez regardé d'ailleurs les raisons
pour lesquelles l'approvision du RN a
été rejetée absolument Patrice alors en
réalité c'est vrai que vous disiez c'est
vrai que c'est un serpent de mer cette
cette proposition de loi puisque ça
revient très récurrent alors j'ai noté
le nom
il faut le préciser parce que alors
parfois on croit que ça a été autrefois
non ça n'a jamais été obligatoire dans
la loi
la seule alors par contre il y a eu des
expérimentations il y a des villes et
des établissements scolaires qui ont mis
en place dans leur règlement intérieur
l'obligation du port de l'uniforme mais
en réalité ces expérimentations elles
ont tourné assez vite cours et j'en
parlerai après si vous me le permettez
puisque en réalité la difficulté qu'il y
a lorsque vous posez une obligation
c'est la sanction corrélative de la du
nom respect de l'obligation et dans ces
hypothèses là les établissements
mettaient en place la nécessité de
porter un uniforme mais derrière en
réalité vu qu'il y avait pas de sanction
pour les étudiants les élèves qui ne
portaient pas l'uniforme et bien très
très vite il était abandonné et
effectivement alors la loi c'est
propositions de loi elles sont revenues
en 2015 en 2017 en 2018 en 2020 elles
sont à chaque fois déposées par des
députés différents et à chaque fois
elles sont balayées parce que on voit
qu'il y a des vraies difficultés
concernant alors les débats sur la la
perspective de mettre cela en oeuvre et
aussi le contenu même des la proposition
qui bon déjà trouve ne sont pas
extrêmement fournis la dernière les
raisons pour lesquelles la commission de
la culture et de l'éducation à refusé
c'est que déjà premièrement il n'y a pas
de points d'accord sur le champ
d'application de la loi est-ce que on le
met l'uniforme à l'école au collège
[Musique]
il faut les trois il y en a certains qui
disent oui mais à l'école ces
problématiques parce que ce sont des
marqueurs importants il faut quand même
laisser les élèves s'habiller comme ils
veulent il faut pas trop les brider donc
déjà là-dessus il n'y a pas d'accord
deuxièmement il y a pas de précision
donc c'est là où on voit qu'en réalité
on envoie
ce serpent de mer sans véritablement de
volonté politique derrière que ça se
fasse c'est que il y a un problématique
sur le champ d'application c'est ce que
je vous disais avant c'est que on pose
une obligation et après on sait pas
comment on sait pas ce qui découle de
cette et comment concrètement on met en
place un uniforme à l'école est-ce que
la problématique c'est est-ce que il
faut permettre à aux élèves d'avoir
uniforme pour que ça gomme les marqueurs
sociaux parce que le grand argument
c'est ça c'est que là le différent
aujourd'hui ce sont les marques roux et
il y a ceux qui ont la possibilité
déjà c'est basket jogging et casquette à
l'envers donc
on va finir on va jamais réussir à tenir
la promesse de ne pas tenir de propos à
vraiment dans l'émission
c'est compliqué et en réalité alors le
problème c'est que vous mettez en place
en uniforme à l'école et ça c'est jamais
résolu dans les propositions de loi
derrière qui finance pour justement
gommer ces marqueurs sociaux mais infini
qui finance le costume le costume ah oui
est-ce que c'est aux parents de
l'acheter si jamais ce sont les parents
à fixer cela ça veut dire que la loi va
poser le principe derrière les
établissements dans le cadre de
réglement intérieur vont devoir définir
le principe donc est-ce que ce seront
les parents qui vont devoir financer ou
est-ce que ce seront les écoles qui
financeront donc les écoles dans le
règlement intérieur vont devoir définir
le coût de l'univers si jamais le coup
est trop élevé certains parents vont
dire oui mais écoutez moi je n'ai pas
les moyens de pouvoir financer un ou
deux uniformes à cette hauteur là donc
finalement le problème revient
identiquement si jamais ce ne sont pas
les parents qui financent mais l'école
vous allez avoir à nouveau une
difficulté pour les écoles qui vont dire
écoutez on a une difficulté par rapport
à nos budgets par rapport à nos
équipements par rapport à nos
enseignants et vous nous demandez encore
pour une raison qui est extrêmement
interrogatif de financer des uniformes
pour les élèves donc à nouveau c'est là
où on voit que on envoie cette
problématique et un principe
à une potentielle application de cette
obligation de l'uniforme et bien on voit
qu'on va arriver très très sur des
points de blocage qui auront beaucoup
beaucoup de difficultés à être résolus
très honnêtement moi enfin moi j'ai
porté l'uniforme dans un collège je veux
dire il y avait c'était un pantalon gris
et veste les heures bleues il y avait
absolument toute latitude pour prendre
une qualité moins d'une qualité
supérieure etc le seul truc vraiment
distinctif c'est un écusson sur la poche
voilà je dis à personne n'était là en
train de dire est-ce que c'est du terial
est-ce que c'est du lin est-ce que c'est
du coton est-ce que donc voilà
maintenant sur le coup je vois pas
tellement le problème les gens en ce
moment ne vont pas cul nu à l'école donc
c'est bien les parents qui leur achètent
ces survêtements qu'ils rachète ses blue
jeans donc pourquoi est-ce que ce serait
difficile qu'ils achètent autre chose le
coup du financement n'a aucun intérêt à
mon sens là si c'est juste comme ça je
ne dis pas du tout que je suis pour
l'uniforme mais si c'est juste parce que
on sait pas comment le financer alors je
ne comprends plus rien
ça va quand même poser une difficulté
puisque alors à l'époque dans un
établissement dans lequel vous étiez
c'était un établissement et là on
parlerait de quelque chose qui
s'appliquerait de manière générale donc
il faudrait quand même pour un uniforme
une forme d'uniformité et donc ça peut
poser des difficultés dans certains
endroits dans certains à certaines dans
certaines situations dans lesquelles et
on le sait des parents sont peut-être
moins favorisés aurait peut-être plus de
difficultés à financer les uniformes et
concernant la qualité alors on est bien
on est bien d'accord que ils pourront
choisir différentes qualités mais
toujours est-il que ce problème de
financement dans certains endroits sera
quand même problématique
parce qu'on contraint le choix des
parents donc là à partir du moment où on
contraint leur choix forcément ça
rajoute la difficulté et votre exemple
est intéressant mais
obligé de discriminer la question pour
un garçon et la question pour une fille
peut-être un peu différent parce que
pour les filles se posent aussi la
question de savoir si elles ont envie de
porter une jupe quelle est la longueur
de la jupe ça peut faire un débat la
longueur de la jupe dessus en dessous du
genou l'emporte
le pantalon à la fille
en réalité c'est censé compenser de
difficultés la première c'est les
marqueurs sociaux et la deuxième le
respect voilà le respect de la laïcité à
l'école en disant bon voilà et on a
recensé quelques problématiques
concernant l'application du principe de
laïcité on met un uniforme et c'est
censé tout gommer mais à nouveau donc on
a parlé là déjà assez longuement de la
question de la l'application de la mise
en oeuvre d'un uniforme sur le point des
marqueurs sociaux mais sur le point de
la laïcité il faut aussi admettre qu'il
y a déjà une loi qui existe qui est
relativement ancienne de 2004 de 2004
qui impose que dans les enceintes
scolaires il n'y est pas de port
exactement de sa religieux
on est en train de noyer le poisson avec
l'histoire de marqueurs sociaux c'est
pas le problème de l'école c'est pas
parce qu'on aura un uniforme que on va
arriver à une inégalité
la mixité à l'école le problème il est à
prendre d'une façon tout à totalement
différente alors les marqueurs sociaux
on va les retrouver même avec un
uniforme on va les retrouver est-ce
qu'on va aller jusqu'au chaussures
est-ce que les filles vont avoir telle
ou tel sac qu'est-ce que je dois avoir
le droit aux boucles d'oreilles alors
moi il se trouve que aussi quand j'étais
petite j'étais dans une école privée
catholique privée quel est un uniforme
[Musique]
bon voilà ça se passe comme ça
[Rires]
les grandes au dessus parce qu'après
j'étais au lycée les grandes
sortaient de l'établissement avec leur
uniforme elles allaient se planquer un
Porsche et alors là
le rouge à lèvres et le Tintin donc le
marqueur sociaux non le problème encore
une fois c'est une façon de noyer le
poisson les marqueurs sociaux la mixité
on veut la mixité aller à l'école c'est
pas comme ça qu'on l'a fait parce que
c'est pas une fausse façon de régler un
vrai problème parce que c'est justement
votre Ministre de l'éducation
mais qui est formidable
je pense qu'on nous a enlevé Blanquer
pour ce personnage
enfin bref même pas Andy reconnaît que
il y a un véritable problème dans
beaucoup beaucoup d'établissements sur
une sorte de travestissement de
certaines tenues qui sont pas détenus
des tenues de
évidemment
plutôt musulmane et islamiste et que il
y a des tonnes de choses
c'est une façon lutter contre ça il y a
énormément de proviseurs qui se
plaignent qui bah voilà qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire parce que c'est des tenues
les élèves arrivent à ce grimer pour
passer les contrôles et puis après on
sait très bien que c'est en fait une
sorte de déclinaison d'une tenue qui
n'est pas une tenue laïque et qui est
une tenue qui normalement devrait être
interdite et peut-être que dans ce
problème là c'est peut-être simplement
cette idée de dire l'uniforme peut-être
faciliterait la vie des proviseurs qui
n'en peuvent plus de savoir si ils
peuvent accepter ceci accepter cela
surveiller que tel jupe ne se transforme
pas en robe
très connoté religieusement etc c'est ça
après effectivement vous avez tous
raison c'est probablement et surtout
vous l'implication la forêt peut-être
que ces autres choses c'est ça débouche
sur un problème d'autorité sur des
tonnes de problèmes et que peut-être que
plein de problèmes dans l'école
n'aura pas probablement que le le bord
de l'uniforme
c'est un signe de de représentants de
dire attention on est ici le plus
moderne qui soit quand même moi la
modernité c'est c'est mon avis la
difficulté du gouvernement c'est qu'on
sait très bien qu'il y a un manque de
dotation absolue que ce soit dans
l'école dans la santé dans la justice et
à chaque fois on essaye de mettre des
pansements sur des jambes de bois avec
des pseudos réforme dont on sait qu'en
réalité elle procède quand même plus
d'effets d'annonce que de réforme
structurelles qui servirait à quelque
chose et en réalité s'il y avait en
réalité s'il y avait un fonctionnement
correct de l'école avec les moyens
nécessaires pour que une bonne éducation
soit donnée on aurait sans doute pas
aujourd'hui ce débat et Macron aurait
sans doute pas brandi à nouveau la
question du de l'uniforme pour essayer
de ne pas lier assez difficultés un mot
un mot sur ce que vous disiez vous
disiez bon ça la position de Brigitte
Macron est d'autant plus
incompréhensible que il y a cette
proposition de loi déposée par
augmentational alors
je peux poser la question un peu
différent est-ce qu'il faut toujours se
sur un sujet se demander d'où on parle
comme on dit c'est dans 68 ou est-ce
qu'il pousse dire est-ce qu'on est pour
ou contre pour contre le port de
l'uniforme est-ce que c'est pas est-ce
que c'est parce que ça vient de
l'extrême droite etc qu'il faut être
contre ou est-ce que ça joue est-ce que
ça doit jouer pourquoi
un certain nombre de personnalités qui
prenaient une position je savais très
bien qu'il fallait prendre la position
inverse oui mais normalement dans ce cas
normalement Brigitte Macron aurait dû
prendre la position inverse puisque ils
sont contre l'extrême droite
que le rassemblement national parce
qu'il y a tout de même une majorité de
députés LR qui sont qui sont pour or
pour le moment même une majorité de
Français oui mais là politiquement la
majorité LR c'est important dans le
présent et là on arrive au contraire
on fait on fait tout de même des avances
du côté il y a ça derrière peut-être ça
peut ça peut être quelque chose
unique uniforme donc il y a tout ça mais
ça ça c'est oui
voilà voilà
c'est bon ce vertu que je verrai en
terme de si on le considère que le
vêtement la communication non verbale la
seule le seul intérêt aux vêtements
c'est d'obliger les individus dans le
sein de la classe à se démarquer
autrement que par une marque ou un logo
elle se démarquée par leur intelligence
en quelque sorte donc
ça peut être au moins une augmentation
différente
passe sur ce que l'on porte mais ce que
l'on est et essayer de communiquer là
pour le coup non pas de façon non
verbale mais de façon verbale et de
parce que l'école elle est pas tellement
là pour vous apprendre à vous vêtir de
en suivant tel ou tel mode elle est là
pour vous apprendre à vous exprimer à
l'oral comme à l'écrit je pense que
c'est c'est là où il faudrait peut-être
revenir à ces valeurs fondamentales
on passe au deuxième sujet parce que
c'est évidemment le 16 semaines décisive
sur les retraites et avec cette question
est-ce que la contestation peut gagner
[Musique]
il y aurait une mobilisation je crois
que c'est pas un secret pour personne
que probablement très forte je dis
puisqu'il y a le front une idée
syndicats
la question est de savoir si c'est c'est
manifestations et ces prises de position
sont populaires ou pas seront suivies
dans l'opinion il y a des sondages
derrière un sondage qui vient de
paraître qui est assez étonnant où les
Français sont favorables à une réforme
de la retraite mais pas celle qui est
présentée en fait ils sont favorables
aux mesures les plus les plus douces et
défavorables à l'âge de 64 ans et elle a
et au 42 ou 43 ans d'annuité
c'est compliqué de savoir si ce qui va
se passer dans les prochains jours non
oui oui c'est compliqué mais dans les
prochains jours vous avez bien dit parce
que je dis je pense qu'on sait que la
mobilisation il va y avoir une
mobilisateur importante c'est depuis 12
ans que il y a une interse syndicale
c'est-à-dire que il va y avoir tous les
habitants voilà en même temps faut
savoir que les les syndicats ne sont pas
en très très bonne santé non et que
peut-être ils envisagent déjà la suite
de ne pas brûler toute leur cartouches
tes jeudis
la proposition ça doit passer en conseil
des ministres ça passe passer à
l'Assemblée nationale tout ça va
s'étendre sur des semaines il faut qu'il
tienne la longueur
il faut il faut
pas partir après
en même temps je sais pas c'est très
difficile d'analyser ce qui va se passer
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a une sorte on
sait une sorte d'apathie de l'op moins
de d'une façon générale enfin
résignation
les Français ont envie de réformer je
pense qu'ils ont compris la nécessité
d'une réforme une seule pas exactement
laquelle mais en même temps ils ont un
côté un peu freerider c'est-à-dire
opportuniste au sens où ils veulent bien
qu'on modifie à condition c'est les
impacts pas donc et on est dans cette
réforme dès qu'on est sur quelque chose
à être partagé et bien on veut bien
profiter mais on veut pas partager le
coup on veut bien profiter et donc
partager les avantages donc ça ça peut
être un souci pour les syndicats je
pense que les menaces sont beaucoup plus
efficaces que passer à l'acte donc la
menace de grève quand on voit ce que ça
provoque ne serait-ce que la fréquente
donc on voit bien que tout à l'heure on
a une incitation il y a une capacité à
après vous le disiez aussi pour lancer
des menaces il faut être crédible et la
confiance dans les syndicats comme la
confiance dans toutes les dans nombre
d'organisations représentatives et
politiques les syndicats étaient à 46%
de confiance au mois de décembre ils ne
sont plus qu'à 31 la côte de popularité
d'exécutif n'est pas non plus en
excédent enfin il y a un tiers pour et
deux tiers rencontre de mécontents donc
on a une situation la représentativité
politique syndicale sociale à pose
problème et en France on n'a pas
d'obligation de d'adhésion syndicat donc
l'adhésion syndicat pour moi ne veut
rien dire ce sont les élections les
élections sociales qui donnent une idée
de la façon dont on apprécie ou pas
l'action du syndicat maintenant ça ne va
pas certainement les empêcher d'agir et
puis il faudra bien faire la différence
entre la direction syndicale et la base
parce que la base peut parfois dépasser
aussi les organisateurs on l'a vu en 95
des grandes grèves au départ on sentait
la CFDT assez finalement pas forcément
opposé et puis elle s'est laissée
dépasser par la base donc oui
95 avec un blocage complet ou 2003 où il
y avait eu des grosses grèves mais
finalement qui s'était arrêté
essoufflées au bout d'un moment ça va
être le baptême du feu de Laurent Nunez
aussi oui
grosse journée pour le projet de police
et puis on peut craindre et là
et puis d'un autre côté des syndicats
que vous disiez qui sont perte de
vitesse et qui ont ils sont obligés
aussi de gagner enfin les deux parties
sont obligés de gagner ce qui ce qui est
quand même donne une situation très
tendue et au final ça peut être tout le
monde perdant tout ce perdant et pardon
et des salariés également parce que
finalement toutes ces grèves on va avoir
des coups d'opportunités des manques à
gagner vous ne pouvez pas prendre des
transports en commun vous allez trouver
une situation vous ne pouvez pas mettre
les enfants à l'école vous allez devoir
et à chaque fois il y a des coûts
supplémentaires donc tout ce manque à
gagner globalement et d'un point de vue
je dirais macroéconomique c'est
peut-être pas des points mais c'est
peut-être une partie d'un point de PIB
en moins donc ça peut aller jusqu'à un
point de PIB un peu moins mais on peut
le voir et est-ce qu'on a vraiment les
moyens entre guillemets aujourd'hui de
se priver de ces occasions de d'avoir un
peu de résilience de la France est assez
satisfaite pour l'instant disant que on
fait moins bien moins mal que les autres
c'est pas terrible mais on fait moins
mal que les autres sur le plan de la
façon le chômage la situation n'est pas
dramatique donc les choses pour être
contenu est-ce que c'est vraiment le
moment de donner un coup sur la tête à
l'économie de voilà et ça c'était
c'était notre problématique c'était je
crois que c'est François Hollande qui
disait ça est-ce que c'est le moment
quand il y a l'inflation quand il y a la
crise énergétique de
taper sur la tête des Français si on
peut dire avec cette réforme qui était
peut-être pas aussi urgentes
pour faire une réforme si il y a un
moment d'un point de vue politiquement
économique c'est le lendemain des
élections
plus d'état de grâce donc à partir du
moment il y a plus cette crédibilité
dont on pourrait déstocker on ne peut
plus déstocker en crédibilité enfin je
dis on exécutif ne peut plus ou
difficilement déstocker des crédibilité
parce que le premier mois 60% de
satisfait et des mois suivants on est
aussi entre 40 même pas 30%, c'est ça le
problème est-ce que c'est pas un
problème institutionnel Armelle le bras
je parle
au premier tour d'une élection un
président élu il a 25 26% et au bout
d'un moment passé passé cet état de
grâce qui est plus en plus court il
revient à son étirage du premier tour
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a 70 % des gens qui
sont opposés à la politique qui fait on
en est là non
il faut qu'il faudrait régler ça dire
qu'il faudrait peut-être avoir la
précision qu'il y a plus de 26 % au
premier tour pour qu'il puisse faire une
politique oui mais alors ça devient
compliqué aussi parce que
on dira que si supposons qu'il n'y ait
qu'un seul tour donc il faudrait que bon
il pourrait être élu à
26%. on est on va contester sa
légitimité le second tour c'est
artificiel mais second tour il y a plus
que deux personnes et il est obligé
d'avoir plus de la moitié des suffrages
quand même un problème le problème se
pose surtout pour ce second mandat parce
que
en plus il y a les élections à
l'Assemblée nationale qui lui donne une
majorité
relative donc c'est effectivement une
question de légitimité alors on
l'apprend en disant bon il n'a pas de
légitimité où on reste très légaliste et
institutionnel en disant vous l'avez lu
prenez les prenez là comme il est
certain pendant ce discours de dire on
l'a élu mais on n'a pas voté pour lui on
a voté contre l'autre exactement
mais dans ces cas-là il faut assumer son
vote on peut pas voter pour quelqu'un et
voter tout en voie ton compte voter pour
tout en votant contre son programme
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure c'est
à dire que bon probablement on voit bien
ce qui va se passer c'est à dire qu'il
va y avoir à l'Assemblée une alliance
entre le Renaissance à la majorité
présidentielle et une grosse partie de
LR1 et que par conséquent la réforme
peut passer sans avoir recours au 49-3
il y a ça et vous avez en même temps 70%
des Français qui sont qui sont opposés à
la réforme
il y a quand même un hiatus entre ce qui
est la majorité parlementaire et ce qui
est peut-être la majorité de l'opinion
ça aussi ça qui montre qu'il y a 68%
ceux qui sont opposés à cette
sens-tu pour cent ils se disent bon de
toute façon ça va passer cette
résiliation
une réforme qui a plus au peuple je
crois pas donc de toute façon
bien évidemment oui on peut dire ah bah
c'est il y a bien gardien qui va nous
inventer une retraite à 32 ans
c'est très amusant parce que les gens se
disent oui il faut une réforme et
qu'est-ce que vous voulez comme réforme
et ils disent ben une pension plus forte
mais on veut pas travailler plus voilà
et alors il y a pardon vous dites
quelque chose
il y a un problème qui moi me semble
intéressant il y a une phrase de Laurent
Berger qui dit même si il y a pas une
forte mobilisation euh il y aura un
ressentiment qui s'exprimera
différemment et c'est vrai que si on
prend
c'est-à-dire le travail pendant
longtemps représenté la libération
l'émancipation c'est la pression je sais
pas si j'ai des résultats mais
qu'aujourd'hui le rapport au travail
d'abord il est beaucoup moins en train
de changer chez les jeunes mais même
chez les c'est des gens qui travaillent
ça devient un boulot un peu un peu dur
un peu difficile
il y a plus cette notion de
d'émancipation par le travail donc le
rapport au travail a changé demandez aux
gens de travailler plus compliqué que ça
n'aurait pu l'être il y a quelques
années alors le rapport là à la
conception du travail bon a changé
depuis l'Antiquité c'était le travail
des esclaves c'était bon très mal vu
avec le surtout au 19e siècle c'est vous
l'avez dit l'émancipation par le travail
à condition que donc
et depuis quelques depuis quelques
années on a vu des Colocs sur le droit à
la fainéantise et maintenant le travail
n'a plus cette valeur mais
parler du travail comme ça en général il
faut parler de la qualité du travail
c'est le basculement c'est aussi du
passage de 35 heures c'est à dire que
quand on est passé au 35 heures on
faisait plus de temps
oisif et parce que la civilisation de
loisirs n'est pas arrivée on a dit aux
gens travailler moins pour faire quoi 9
heures avant si c'est pour regarder la
télévision
ils font des tas de choses non mais le
rapport
demandé c'est l'exploitation de l'homme
par l'homme n'avait pas été remplacé par
l'exploitation de l'homme par le travail
dans les années 70 il y avait déjà ses
débats ça avait été un peu effacé ces
débat justement
mais bon après sur le sur le temps de
travail il y avait des il y avait il y a
quand même eu des recherches vous avez
probablement raison mais ça c'est le
constat et après ça nous mène où c'est
vrai que voilà la vraie question
plus personne ne travaille c'est plus
personne n'a envie de se lever le matin
si plus personne si tout le monde dit
ouais le boulot c'est pas très important
car tout le monde ne peut pas vivre au
fin fond du Larzac avec une chèvre et
deux poules enfin je veux dire c'est
c'est c'est c'est gentil
j'espère bien mais le secret du boulot
mais il y a des centaines de milliers
d'offres d'emploi non pourvu les
restaurants les hôtels les cafés les
boucheries sont en train de fermer faute
de
salariés évidemment
travaille ou non travail
c'est à la plateforme de de la Fargue la
question c'est qu'est-ce que le travail
représente qu'est-ce qu'il est qu'est-ce
que c'est quelle est la quelle est la
qualité si on est heureux au travail il
y en a qui sont heureux au travail
il y a pas de problème il y a pas de
problème de temps après il y a les
questions de pénibilité même quelqu'un
qui est heureux au travail n'a pas envie
de partir à 70 ans ou même à 65 ans mais
c'est ça c'est alors déjà les choses se
sont modifiées en particulier avec
l'épidémie covid avec le télétravail le
télétravail permet d'avoir du temps
enfin d'organiser son temps il y a une
question d'organisation de travail de
contenu du travail c'est pas la même
chose d'être dans une une chaîne et
d'être
enseignant voilà c'est ce que vous
disiez en réalité on est passé d'un
aspect quantitatif où on considérait que
le travail était nécessaire parce que ça
permettait une émancipation à sur les
générations actuelles à un aspect
beaucoup plus qualitatif pénibilité le
thème de pénibilité il est il est
absolument plus vaste que n'était et
alors après c'est vrai qu'on pourrait
aussi s'interroger sur
la négociation sociale c'est à dire que
dans les pays du nordique enfin quand on
fait des réformes comme ça et les
syndicats et les
un travail pendant des années là il y a
une proposition qui arrive entre les
enfin pendant la campagne présidentielle
retraite au 65 ans mais il sait bien que
ça fait longtemps qu'on parle de pour le
nôtre de retraite mais il y a peut-être
un mot aussi de concertation sociale
dialogue social c'est la culture
syndicale en France depuis
les débuts vous étiez les pays nordiques
les pays nordiques fonctionnent au
consensus on a on arrive François
Hollande a essayé avec le dialogue
social bon il n'est pas parvenu mais il
faut voir comment se sont historiquement
construits les syndicats en France et la
CGT en particulier c'était l'anarchos
syndicaliste c'est-à-dire qu'ils avaient
une volonté de renverser la table et de
renverser la société d'où aujourd'hui et
ce qui complique de ce dialogue social
c'est le rapport au parti politique il y
a une concurrence entre les syndicats et
les partis politiques et on va le voir
la CGT en particulier ne veut pas que
LCI
donc c'est cette culture fait aussi et
explique aussi la faible
adhésion numériquement parlant au
syndicat donc c'est parce qu'on a des
frères
rider ils veulent bien des effets de la
de l'action syndicale mais ils veulent
pas adhérer au syndicat parce que leur
réputation pour en souffrir vis-à-vis du
management par exemple donc je suis
finalement aussi bien le titre si je ne
suis pas syndiqué aussi je suis syndiqué
en France j'aurais les mêmes avantages
je ne vais pas subir le coup de me faire
grève de manifester de me faire
identifier comme étant syndiqué c'est
pas forcément
des comparaisons avec les pays nordiques
parce que les pays nordiques c'est
sympathique mais c'est une petite
dizaine de millions d'habitants en Suède
c'est quand même beaucoup plus facile de
gérer cette quantité de population
donc voilà
un système politique
présidentielle direct
[Musique]
il y a un syndicalisme hypertrophié bien
sûr on va passer à vous parce que quand
on parle de la réforme de retraite on
parle toujours des prévisions du corps
et alors il y a toujours des prévisions
comme ça alors concernant concernant la
croissance l'inflation le budget et et
vous avez regardé au fond quelle est la
différence entre les prévisions que nous
annonce les organismes officiels ou le
gouvernement et la réalité voilà parce
que quand j'entends parler de l'État
j'ai toujours l'impression de devoir
Janus c'est-à-dire dans l'état l'état
montre deux visages enfin il a deux
visages il a celui qui montre il y a ce
qu'on voit et ce qu'on ne voit pas
lorsque l'État ne dit pas et l'idée
c'est d'aller un peu plus un peu plus
loin
l'environnement étant incertain la
nécessité de la prévision
apparent à part apparaît à part pour
tout le monde nécessité de la réduire
l'incertitude pour tout le monde te dire
qu'on a des choix à faire plus on a
d'informations plus a priori on peut
réduire cette incertitude qui
disparaîtra pas parce que le risque zéro
n'existe pas le risque de se tromper est
toujours là et pour tout le monde alors
on a plusieurs indicateurs quand on
regarde alors là on est sur du très long
terme et de la croissance par exemple
sur la croissance on a pris les choses
on a un bout de la quatrième et on a
alors sur la croissance en parlant on a
uniquement en 1980 en rouge c'est quand
on surestime voilà on a on a les
évolutions
concernant la croissance sur la période
de 8 à 2022 on a eu 42 dates et on a
plus de surestimation on a 22 périodes
de surestimation et le reste pour des
sous-estimations et on a un cas où deux
cas 97 avec
et 2014 avec Valls ou le la croissance a
bien été anticipé a bien été prévu
d'accord donc ça c'est finalement voilà
c'est comment on peut conduire la
politique économique on a besoin
d'indicateurs et sur les indicateurs il
faut faire des projections des
anticipations et l'opinion alors pour le
pour le gouvernement je veux dire il
vaut mieux
sous-estimé parce qu'on se dit bah c'est
mieux que ce qu'on pensait alors parfois
c'est pas volontaire si on peut juste
avant c'est un peu sur les sur les
graphiques et je vais vous montrer tout
à la fin sur l'inflation on peut pas
faire grand-chose aujourd'hui en France
parce que la Banque centrale européenne
dirige la politique monétaire et on fait
pas une politique monétaire pour la
France mais on l'a fait pour le pour
l'Europe donc finalement on échappe et
la lutte contre l'inflation on nous
l'impose une politique monétaire
restrictive finalement le gouvernement
français a pas grand chose à dire sur le
sujet sur les 7 périodes on a trois
périodes de surestimation trois périodes
de sous-estimation très fortes en 2022
bien sûr puisque personne n'a vu venir
l'inflation
5,9 on avait prévu
on était dans une logique de 100% même
pas on n'avait pas assez d'inflation
alors que la banque centrale est là pour
lutter contre l'inflation
parce que l'orthodoxie monétaire est
héritée d'Allemagne et de dire pas plus
de 2% mais là on en était même pas là on
a même pas 2 % on attendait finalement
on en voulait un peu parce que
l'inflation quand elle est pas assez
forte elle peut être finalement
désincitative au travail et et à la
croissance et puis on a dernier un
dernier tableau qui est sur le sol
budgétaire c'est là où on a un peu de la
quatrième et de la 5e est-ce qu'il
commence en 1954 en 1955 la première
prévision le gouvernement annoncé un
déficit il avait un excellent donc là
c'est quand même un cas très très
antinomique et puis on voit bien que les
écarts sont plus importants vers la fin
que que que que que sont les débuts de
la période voilà et ce qui nous
intéresse finalement c'est de dire
personne n'est à le prix d'une erreur
pas même vous quand vous prévoyez et
l'état non plus mais quand on regarde
bien on a un outil statistique qui
s'appelle des coefficients de taille peu
importe et c'est un outil statistique
qui permet de décomposer l'erreur autour
de trois causes et quand on a quand on
listé les choses
il y a une erreur qui va consister à
systématiquement sous-estimer ou
surestimer et là c'est c'est l'État dans
sa vision manipulatrice
c'est mieux si c'était pire on va
essayer de climatiser l'opinion le
problème c'est qu'on peut pas toujours
le faire ou qu'on n'est pas toujours en
état de faire parce que parfois deuxième
risque d'erreur c'est on n'a pas le bon
outil on n'a pas le bon modèle alors on
a les outils statistiques parce que ce
n'est pas le gouvernement qui fait des
prévisions généralement il est consensus
des économistes des instituts de la
Banque de France et puis on peut
regarder aussi le FMI etc et donc il a
il a pas le bon outil oui il ne sait pas
bien poser les hypothèses et ça c'était
le cas de Sarkozy le mauvais outil 57%
de de l'erreur et des difficultés
apprécient le budget ont été dû à ces
difficultés d'utiliser le type et puis
le troisième c'est ben finalement ce que
je disais tout à l'heure le risque que
une variable non contrôlée les chocs
imprévisibles merci Benoît
personne ne pouvait le prévoir et ça
réduit la marge de manœuvre ça donne la
finalement ça ça réduit la marge de
manœuvre ça peut faire paraître plus
honnête le responsable politique parce
que finalement on se dit il ne manipule
pas mais ça lui tombe sur la tête et là
il n'a aucune marge de manœuvre ni
budgétaire ni autre et finalement quand
on regarde les choses si j'ai si j'ai
encore un petit peu de temps ce qu'on
peut dire c'est que à force d'avoir ces
éléments et de ne pas pouvoir maîtriser
la politique économique on s'aperçoit
qu'on ne fait que des réformes
conjoncturelles et on auto-entretien les
difficultés plutôt
et la manipulation elle aussi son
paradoxe mais je vous le dirai plus tard
une prochaine fois parce qu'on a pas le
temps
très clair c'était très clair et je note
que l'erreur rend l'homme politique plus
honnête et plus sincère
la question que je me pose sur le
premier point sous-estimation si tu
restimulation donc il peut y avoir un
manipulation là oui mais il y a tout de
même des organismes indépendants qui
font leur propre projection et qui
peuvent aller contre le gouvernement une
prévision généralement l'état fait un
peu la synthèse il y a le consensus des
économistes donc là déjà
et puis il y a des institutions la
Banque de France pour le pour
l'inflation c'est souvent la Banque de
France qui a des statistiques les plus
faciles à suivre parce qu'il y a aussi
les agences de notation qui font leur
prévision parce que et l'image que la
France envoie par les prévisions ça
aussi une incidence sur sa crédibilité à
l'extérieur sur le fait qu'on va avoir
une bonne note une mauvaise note et
qu'on pourra emprunter de façon plus ou
moins coûteuse et donc tout est tout est
important c'est de la communication les
annonces génère des effets d'annonce
parce qu'il y a un contenu d'information
dedans et qui sera interprété et vous ne
vous maîtrisez la prévision mais vous ne
maîtrisez pas la façon dont elle est
reçue et interpréter et le ressenti et
des agents et des entreprises et des
institutions et nous et de nos
partenaires partenaires économiques en
l'occurrence donc c'est merci beaucoup
on passe au alors un petit sujet qui est
intéressant c'est ce sondage c'est la
troisième partie pourquoi les jeunes
croient de moins en moins on la science
[Musique]
alors voilà oui la proportion de de
jeunes de 18 à 24 ans qui perçoivent
positivement la science ça me chuter de
22 points depuis quelques années depuis
72 mois ça c'est une chute consécutive
et va que oui qui ne s'arrête pas et et
en fait c'est assez intéressant parce
que alors si on regarde oui c'est vrai
que il y a beaucoup de jeunes qui ne
croient pas que les Américains sont
allés sur la lune qui ne qui ne croient
pas enfin il y a plein de vérita
alternatives il va son 25% à penser
qu'on peut avorter son risque avec des
produits à base de plantes par exemple
c'est comment on explique vers les
enseignants peut-être d'abord comment
vous êtes jamais responsable
peut-être responsable
justement que c'est effectivement un
problème d'éducation d'éducation
jusqu'au jusqu'au lycée enfin jusqu'à la
fin de la fin du lycée
où on insiste peut-être passer sur
beaucoup de choses et puis ensuite après
je veux dire c'est une population enfin
de la population qui est cité dans ce
dans sondage qui ne lit absolument plus
rien ou presque alors
des réseaux sociaux c'est que
d'accord la vraie difficulté c'est
l'accès des jeunes à l'information et ce
sur quoi il se nourrissent et se
renseigne et on voit le problème avec
notamment TikTok qui est ce réseau
social chinois sur lequel on trouve
absolument tout et n'importe quoi et qui
a une audience chez les jeunes qui est
absolument incroyable et là qu'on voit
qu'on peut avorter en effet avec du miel
je sais pas quoi faire exactement et
donc la la question qui va se poser à
nouveau et je vois ça à nouveau sur un
angle juridique c'est de savoir comment
est-ce que dans quelques années enfin
dans les années prochaines on va pouvoir
endiguer ce phénomène en permettant une
protection de la jeunesse sur la qualité
à nouveau un aspect qualitatif de
l'information qui sera trouvée sur ces
sur ces réseaux sociaux
leur donner le goût au libre arbitre les
éduquer dans la façon dont il reçoivent
l'information obligé un jugement
critique un peu dans les dans les ça
commence à se faire dans les collèges
dans les lycées il y a des organisations
justement sur savoir
distinguer ce qui relève du conflitisme
ou de la essayer de les faire les
journaux etc il y a aussi le fait que le
négation de la science enfin c'est
abandon des de l'intérêt pour la science
et pour ce que la science peut nous
apporter c'est aussi le
l'idéalisation du non travail
c'est-à-dire que ça ne demande aucune
compétence la science ça demande un peu
de travail ne serait-ce que d'imaginer
de comprendre etc alors que de croire
effectivement comme vous le dites qu'on
peut avorter avec une boule de miel ou
de croire à n'importe quel calandred
paru sur Tik Tok ou sur un tweet par un
influenceur abruti c'est facile donc
c'est rapide
par des extraterrestres mais voilà mais
c'est facile de croire ça c'est facile
et c'est un chanteur alors on se dit bah
oui bah c'est tellement plus amusant de
se
il y a quand même aussi cette cette idée
que tous vous ce qui est un vrai un vrai
problème surtout ce qui nous dévoilera
toutes les vérité qu'elle soit véritable
vérité ou alternative toujours dans un
global je sais pas comment dire non mais
ce genre de d'explication le mérite
d'être unique c'est comme ça les
extraterrestres ont construit des
pyramides et puis on cherche pas à autre
chose mais je crois qu'il faut devoir
plus loin et évidemment les réseaux
sociaux sont très responsables à ces
sujets tel que le refus d'une certaine
façon de la science c'est le refus de la
raison et quand il y a pas la raison eh
ben on met la foi à côté et je pense que
ça renvoie un problème beaucoup plus
général
qu'on voit et dont on reparle aussi très
souvent qui est le retour du religieux
alors c'est pas le retour du religieux
dans le sens d'une religion encore que
encore que dans certaines catégories
mais
il vaut mieux croire que que réfléchir
que que penser canaliser parce que c'est
c'est déstabilisant de raisonner la
science et déstabilisante à la belle et
pas non plus la vérité avec un grand V
il y a le doute qui s'instaure avec ce
genre de choses et ben au moins on a la
recette on l'applique et puis c'est bon
et en même temps on est dans un monde
qui croient la consommation
technologique est de plus en plus forte
il est pas impossible que les choses
évoluent concernant le contrôle de
l'accès à ces informations là puisque
alors en 2018 le gouvernement qui était
soucieux que les élections
présidentielles puissent être manipulées
comme elles l'ont été dans d'autres pays
et comme elles l'ont comme elles ont pu
l'être un petit peu pendant les
élections présidentielles de 2017 a
sorti une loi de prévention contre la
manipulation de l'information dans
l'ordre des élections politiques
mais cette loi elle a aussi un régime
général qui lui permettrait d'être
appliqué sur d'autres domaines pas
strictement sur les temps électoraux et
alors pour l'instant il n'existe pas
encore de dispositifs spécifiques pour
justement arriver à l'application de ce
régime général de cette loi mais très
clairement vu ce qui sort et vu ce qui
est dit dans les médias à propos
justement de l'accès à la science et de
la de la non-croyance de certains de
certains jeunes ça va arriver comme on
est un petit peu en train aussi de
réguler l'accès à certains réseaux
sociaux pour les adolescents parce qu'il
y a pareil une loi assez récente qui a
obligé les réseaux sociaux à instaurer
un contrôle parental obligatoire pour
que avant tout avant tout les parents
puissent faire le filtre avant de donner
l'accès aux adolescents et la boucle est
bouclée
directeurs de Front populaire sur sur
l'affaire Houellebecq et là il y a aussi
la possibilité aussi que les
responsables des réseaux sociaux soit
soit responsable de ce qui s'écrit sur
le ce qui se dit sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est ce à quoi il voudrait je pense
tendre mais la difficulté c'est ses
organes sont tellement puissants d'abord
c'est c'est international mais voilà
mais bon ben merci merci à tous les
quatre malheureusement le voilà on a
bien continué quelques heures mais il
faut s'arrêter qu'est-ce que vous voulez
faire merci beaucoup et à très vite pour
un nouveau numéro de PAF
[Musique]